[Music]
all right now that we're back down to
earth after all of that Vision Pro
launch stuff I've had a chance to go
back and repick up some of the things
that I was testing that got like
interrupted by that week of chaos and
there's some really good stuff the Oppo
findind X7 Ultra design I really like
more than I expected the Zenbook Duo the
full screen dual screen laptop for 2024
is kind of sick and there's some other
stuff that is better than expected but
the one that stood out to me maybe the
most of the small is this guy right here
the OnePlus 12 this may have flown a
little bit under the radar I mean with
everything that's been going on but it's
gotten some improvements from last year
and it is priced very competitively
matter of fact let's just start with
that $7.99 and you also get a free
upgrade to the 16 gigs of RAM half
terabyte model for that price if you
pre-order it's literally already marked
down to that on Amazon so I'll have a
link below Flagship price yes but when
it's competing theoretically against
some of the ult phones 1,000 1200
$1,300 then suddenly it's kind of in the
category of uh dare I say Flagship
killer so look it's nearly the same on
the outside they found what they like
and they're keeping it consistent same
shapes same camera bump Circle that kind
of melts into the side with these neural
details around it it's still Gorilla
Glass 5 on the back and there's a new
set of colors and textures but in
general you'd be forgiven for thinking
it's nearly the same as last year or
maybe you wouldn't but don't let that
fool you up front this screen is I think
the biggest noticeable physical
difference from last year it gets way
brighter up to 1,600 nits outdoors and
it's hitting crazy numbers now 4,500
nits Peak HDR brightness basically it's
super impressive and extremely readable
outdoors and in any light but it also
gets extremely dim too now I don't like
that it's this curved over the edges
like you can see the light fall off and
the extra Reflections that come with
that but basically from corner to corner
this 6.8 in 1440p ltpo Pro xdr display
is a real upgrade over last year so then
the rest of the upgrades to this phone
are definitely a case of a bunch of
little changes all like stacking up on
top of each other to equal a large
difference from last year does that make
sense like that's that's what
smartphones are nowadays I remember
reviewing the OnePlus One and then the
OnePlus 2 the next year and just the
gigantic total shift big Direction
changes between those two phones
nowadays it's just about like finding a
bunch of clever little things and
stacking a bunch of little improvements
on top of each other just make the user
experience a little better so obviously
if you're going to be a Flagship killer
you got to have the newest chip inside
so it does it's the Snapdragon 8 gen 3
not that you'll notice a whole ton of
difference side by side with a
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 phone but this phone
does have much better cooling as well so
it's giving them some Headroom to play
with slightly boosted clock speeds and
it's benchmarking right behind the
gaming phones and the s24 ultra in real
world use that just means this phone is
super fast really really fluid it's a
smooth phone all the time like this is
something one plus has done really well
for a long time even with high
performance mode being off in the
battery settings by default but speaking
of battery this phone is definitely
prioritizing battery super long battery
life over like Ultra high-end
performance numbers and getting every
last FPS out of the thing and as a
result this is a battery champ first of
all you just start with a huge Capac so
it's got one of the biggest batteries
ever in a OnePlus Flagship it's now a
5400 mAh battery that's bigger than a
lot of other phones that are Ultras now
and you better believe they've kept
their trademark super fast charging also
so it's technically a split battery it's
dual 2700 Milow and it can juice up at
80 Watts wired this combination of huge
battery awesome battery life
prioritization of battery length and
Ultra fast charging honestly makes this
at least a contender to think about
right now for battery champ of the Year
matter of fact if you just leave this
phone and all of its out the boox
settings meaning not in high performance
mode just regular performance mode by
default 1080p which it is out the box
and then just Auto frame rate you can
get two full light days out of this
phone and then when you finally do get
down to near zero you can charge up to
half battery in like 12 minutes if you
want to go all the way full that's only
going to take about half an hour it's
just so easy and on top of all of that
there is up to 50 W wireless charging so
if you've got a compatible Air vuk
charger you obviously have to buy that
separately but the OnePlus 11 didn't
even have wireless charging at all so
this is a gigantic Improvement I almost
want to get greedy and also wish that
there was ch2 support for wireless
charging but I don't know about you but
ch2 has felt like it's off to a weird
Rocky start especially this year it's
been surprisingly uncommon for any
phones to support ch2 with the magnets
and wireless charging this is likely
because there seems to be a 15 watt
charging limit with ch2 for now so if
you want to do fast wireless charging
you aren't doing ch2 so yeah no ch2
Wireless no magnets but very very fast
charging either way way better display
better chip better battery and also now
the cameras have gotten an upgrade now
I'm just going to say cameras have been
a relatively weak point for oneplus's
highest end phones for a while now we've
always wanted to call them Flagship
Killers but people love cameras in
Flagship phones it just hasn't quite
been able to match that highest level
I'd say now it's on the acceptable for a
flagship level but it's not quite
beating those yet and that's still true
about this phone now this main sensor it
is actually very slightly different
instead of the OnePlus open Sony lyt
t808 sensor it is the lyt 808 sensor
it's two more megapixels it's slightly
wider aperture with the glass in front
of it nevertheless basically these
OnePlus 12 photos aren't going to shock
you I've done some side by-side
comparisons I've even said this before
it's pretty good most of the time it's
pretty sharp it's a little contrasti
than the OnePlus open the HDR effect
looks fine it just it falls apart a
little too quickly as soon as there's
adverse conditions especially low light
but here's the thing just for the
context of that it's not that far behind
we've already tested this because we did
the blind smartphone camera test last
year with 20 of the best smartphone
cameras in the world and in that test
was the OnePlus open so yeah there's a
lot of software involved with these
cameras but basically this extremely
similar camera system in the standard
light photo it had the third highest ELO
rating behind the two pixels then in
portrait mode it was also top 10 but in
low light it was fifth from the bottom
right around the Sony and below the
Razer so in summary yeah the camera
system is new it does have new hardware
it has a new zoom and everything but all
together it is just like a lot of the
other stuff I'm showing you a little bit
better than last year and that's going
to be good enough for a lot of people
actually most people most of the time
but if we want to consider it Flagship
it's just there is a little bit of a gap
till it reaches the best but I'll tell
you what they keep they even more keep
stacking it up there are so many little
things about using this OnePlus phone
that I really like like I love that I
can specifically Force any app I want to
be at whatever frame rate I want like
there's literally a list of every single
app on my phone and by default you've
probably noticed all the mapping apps
like ways and Google Maps they always
even on every other 120 HZ phone they
always always override and run at 60 HZ
but on this phone I can just fix it just
give me all the frames please I also
love that this phone has an infrared
blaster one of the least common features
in the world of a modern smartphone
alongside like a headphone jack but yeah
it literally lets you turn on and off
and control appliances remotely without
having to find the remote like this TV
here or or a stranger TV I don't know
it's the little things I love that this
USBC Port not only supports basically
the fastest charging we've ever seen on
a phone in the US but also also supports
extremely fast data transfer speeds this
is a USB 3.2 gen 1 Port the names and
and generations are horrible at this
point and Incredibly confusing all you
really need to know is that this has
basically the best data speeds available
from a USBC phone so if you get the
right cable you can get large files like
videos on and off of the device real
quick and then a lot of you will
probably love that this new screen
supports High pwm dimming if you've
never heard of this before it might not
even matter to you but there is a select
fraction of the population that is
specifically sensitive to the flickering
that becomes visible at super low
brightness with a lot of these
smartphone OLED displays to the point
where like it causes headaches and eye
fatigue so some smartphones including
this one are now addressing it with
super high pulse width modulation
basically they still flicker on and off
to get that lower perceived brightness
but much much faster than the human eye
can perceive 2,160 HZ in this phone's
case so it still appears liquid smooth
at all brightness levels which is
awesome if you use your phone in the
rain or when it's wet you probably
already know how chaotic that feels like
there's memes about it like it it just
seems to kind of act on its own when
there's water droplets on the screen but
this phone claims that with a new
technology called aqua touch it will
totally remain as usable as ever even
with water all over the screen now you
might have seen the ads for it it might
sound ridiculous but it actually works
it's not perfect obviously but you can
definitely feel that it's dramatically
more responsive to the point where I can
actually type things on this wet phone
screen where I just would not want to do
that on any other phone without this
kind of feels like magic I am very
impressed and then there's even just
extra little tiny things on top of that
like 12 or 16 gigs of fast Ram that's
sick futureproof um also Dolby Atmos
with spatial audio support great it also
has great haptics like all this tiny
stuff adds up to be a great overall
experience but it's not perfect right
let's be real no phone is perfect but at
least I can say about this phone that
also the downsides are also a couple
small things like I for one I've already
talked about this but I'm kind of over
the curv displays so this one keeping
that it's not a deal breaker like you
might even argue it's a little more
character to this phone in the world of
2024 smartphones but it definitely has
its downsides from the glare to the
light falloff to the drop test
durability but okay fine they've gone
curved but then the fingerprint sensor
underneath is also still a pretty
average Optical sensor doesn't feel like
it's been upgraded in years and then for
having the new Snapdragon 8 gen 3 chip
inside which a lot of other flagships do
this phone doesn't really have any of
the AI
features like at all and this is
something I wanted to keep an eye on
with all these phones coming out with
this chip early in this year which is
okay Qualcomm puts out a new chip small
performance gains small efficiency gains
but also huge new AI
capabilities and this phone kind of just
skipped the AI part now not that that's
a disaster but those were some genuinely
useful features the only one I found on
this phone is in the photo editor and
it's called AI palettes but it's just
like a color overlay I don't even really
think there's that much AI going on with
this at all so none of that generative
fill crop correction none of that magic
editor stuff none of that auto live
transcription of phone calls or live
translation of phone calls none of that
like speaker labels in The Voice app
none of the auto summaries in the
browser anything like that it's just
none of it it's not on this phone and
then also random bug I don't know every
time I'm in the overlay browser and I
reach up to my favorite little alert
slider on the OnePlus phone and change
modes it opens a search box like to find
in page I don't know why they shouldn't
be connected but it does it every single
time but maybe the biggest legitimate
downside of this phone when you're
comparing in it to the other flagships
it's going up against is it's promised
fewer years of software update support
now I've already gotten a pretty major
software update since I started testing
this phone big camera improvements and
Bug fixes and stuff like that great but
they are only promising only promising
four years of software updates and 5
years of security updates now that's
fine a lot of people only plan on
keeping this phone for 3 or four years
maybe 5 years before I'm moving on to
the next one but in the world of the
flagships the pixel the Samsungs of the
world even the iPhones giving you six or
seven years of software updates this is
just notably behind on that maybe
OnePlus didn't think it was worth the
extra resources it doesn't think people
care that much about it to actually
spend money on it to put the resources
in but yeah four or five versus seven so
is this a Flagship
killer well that just depends on your
definition of a flagship doesn't it I
think this is probably the most
compelling thing about this phone is
going to be how competitively priced it
is because it's very similar in a lot of
ways to let's call it s24 Ultra right
but I've seen this phone the 16 gigs of
RAM half terabyte version for $8.99 on
their site but if you pre-order it you
can get that for
$7.99 but they're also advertising it in
a lot of places for $6.99 because
they're apparently just giving you a 100
bucks for a trade in of any phone in any
condition so if you're going with
$6.99 and this phone starts at 1,300
bucks then yeah that is a damn good deal
so yeah i' just be looking at what's
important to you like if I would say if
camera is really important to you or if
long-term software support is actually
super high on your list or if any of
those AI features looked really
compelling or really interesting that
you'd want them then you'd probably end
up going with one of those other
flagships but for everything else like
for performance for a great screen for
incredible battery super fast charging
Ultra smooth like this phone is is
better than you probably think oh and on
top of all that OnePlus also around the
same time has released this phone right
here it looks almost the same but this
is the OnePlus
12r and this is just a a budgeted TI
budge tized a budget version even more
so than this phone already just
basically cutting a few Corners a few
corners on the camera right it's a
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 instead of the Gen 3
there's no wireless charging things like
that it's uh IP 64 instead of ip65
whatever it's a slightly trimmed down
version again 500
bucks I'm just saying so if these phones
weren't already on your radar they
probably should be thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace